[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
We have here in verses 38-
48 of
surah
is the 74th
successive chapter of the Quran and the
order of the mus.
It is one of the earlier chapters of the
Quran that were revealed to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in Mecca. As we've
mentioned before
the opening verses of
as is in
as is inklusim
the narration of
that this is the second revelation of
Quran to the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam. The first was
the second.
However, we know because of the tone
because of the topics, the subject
matter of
the verses in it are referring to
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's antagonist
namely
al
and others that the subsequent verses of
mud were revealed later on after
the
propaganda and antagonism of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was reaching
a boiling point exact years we're not
sure exact exactly which years. But the
subject matter articulates that these
verses were revealed later on after the
dawa of the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam became public after the
propaganda
that walnam
along with Abu Jaham
and others.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
verse number 38
that every soul
due to what it has earned of sin is held
captive is held ransom by its own doing.
Now we mentioned last night that the
wording of this verse is very precise
because in Christianity there is a
misconception a misunderstanding
with respect to the topic of the
original sin
that
every human being the concept is that
every human being is born into sin
because Adam
committed the first sin. Therefore, we
are all guilty of what the father has
committed. Even though their own book
tells them that
every soul, no soul shall bear the
burden of another with those exact
words. Exactly what we have written in
our book over and over and over
that no soul shall bear the burden of
another. The father shall not bear the
burden of the son and the son shall not
bear the burden of the father. And this
is a major issue because it reflects the
justice of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. It
reflects the justice of Allah
that every soul, every human being who
makes a conscious choice and a conscious
decision to disobey Allah,
the rest of his family and his
subsequent lineage cannot be held to
account for these poor choices. And this
is a misunderstanding that even some
Muslims have. And that is that many
Muslims believe or think or of the
misunderstanding
that Adam alisam was sent out of
paradise as a punishment. That is
grossly incorrect. Adamisam was not
punished
when he was expelled from paradise
because if he was punished that means
that Allah taught him how to repent,
accepted his repentance and then still
punished him. And as Allah subhanahu
waala says with respect to repent
repentance
and he says
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
has said that repentance
erases
what is before it of sin
but it does not erase
consequences of our actions that is the
point here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
told Adam when he was in paradise when
el refused to bow to him as the rest of
the angels Did Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said to Adam,
[Silence]
he said, Subhanah
that Allah said to Adam when he saw
L refused to bow,
refused to acknowledge him, refused the
command of Allah and his enmity and
jealousy and hatred for Adam became very
public and undeniable. He said to him,
"This man is an enemy to you and your
spouse. So be careful that because of
him you are not then expelled from
paradise.
And so that was the agreement. Those
were the terms of the agreement.
Adamisam made the mistake. And so Adam
had in his heart whatl did not. El
disobeyed
and he argued it away
with this flimsy argument. This idea of
Right? He argued away his sin. I'm
better than him. And the real reason I'm
not bowing is because because you know
this is inappropriate anyways because
I'm from I'm cut from a finer cloth than
he is. How could how could I how could I
bow to someone who is lesser than I am?
He didn't say what was really in his
heart. He didn't believe that. He didn't
believe that argument. What was in his
heart is I am too arrogant. He is too
arrogant to bow. He is too jealous and
arrogant to bow. But people they do not
usually have that kind of blunt honesty
when they disobey. They give some kind
of argument. No matter how flimsy, no
matter how silly, some kind of argument
to save face. So he goes into this
rhetoric about who's better and who
comes from who's cut from a finer cloth
and etc etc. However, El didn't believe
that. So his heart didn't have
contrition.
So he was not he did not repent. So he
was banished from paradise and he was
cast was damned to hell for eternity. If
he would have repented, Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala.
Adam
is the opposite.
Ll had the words. He knew how to repent,
but his heart wasn't there. Adam
disobeyed Allah in the same place with
the same clarity of instruction.
However, Adam,
his heart was filled with contrition,
with regret, with remorse, but he didn't
have the words to say how to repent. And
so Allah taught him how to repent. His
heart was there, but his tongue was not.
And so Allah taught him.
And so Adam then received words from
Allah from his Lord and he repented and
Allah accepted his repentance.
How then can we say that Allah accepted
his repentance but still banished him
from paradise? No. This was the direct
consequence of an act that he had
committed. These were the rules and he
broke the rules. His repentance was
accepted but the physical
repercussions of his actions still
remained. We gave an example of this
yesterday. Let's say a person commits
adultery.
A person commits fornication, zena, and
then this person as in doing so
contracts some kind of disease, venerial
disease, but then repents to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Does that make the
disease disappear? He has it no more
because he repented. Of course not.
That's not what that means. What that
means is that Allah may very well have
accepted his repentance. However, the
consequences will remain. And so, we
were not banished from paradise as Adam
was banished from paradise as a
punishment for him and all of his
subsequent lineage. Rather, Adam
was expelled from paradise due to an
issue of cause and effect and a great
wisdom that Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
had for him. And so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala corrects this. He sets the record
straight. He says,
he didn't say
every soul is captive. Every soul is
held captive. He said
that every soul is held captive
by his own sin.
He then says,
"Except for the people of the right."
Now, who are the people of the right?
The people of the right are the people
of paradise.
The people of the right
are called this for three reasons.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
referred to them as the people of the
right.
Allah refers to them as the people of
the right because of three things.
and his
he says they are called the people of
the right because on the day of judgment
they will be to the right of Allah's
throne that's one
number two because they will receive
their book of deeds in their right hand
that's two
number three
because they were on the right side of
Adamisam
on
when the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
went up that
al in the Arabic language
is a ladder or a staircase.
When he subhanahu wa ta'ala went up this
maj
and went into the first heaven, who did
he then find there in the first heaven?
Adam.
And when he met Adam and saw him,
you were there and you and your mother
and your father and I was there and my
mother and my father. Every one of us
was there. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam says in the narration of abd
and others that he had to his right the
souls
of his offspring of the people of
paradise to his right.
And he had to his left the souls the
damned souls of his offspring, the
people of hell to his left. And then
when he looked to his right, he smiled.
And when he looked to his left, he wept.
And that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam asked Gibl.
What is this? Who are these? And he told
him that to his right are the people of
paradise and to his left the people of
hell, the damned,
the hellbound.
And so they are referred to as the
people of the right. Why? As we
mentioned three things, they are to the
right of Allah's throne on the day of
judgment.
Allah has categorized people into three
categories on the day of judgment.
Correct?
Three categories.
Allah mentions these three categories in
number one.
Number two,
number three.
And so we have three categories of
people on the day of judgment. The
people of the right who will be to the
right of Allah's throne on the day of
judgment.
They will receive their book in their
right hand and they were to the right of
Adam on that faithful night.
The second are
those who are ever close to Allah. those
who have been given higher privilege and
nearness to Allah. He says that they
will come and be in direct front of
Allah's throne on the day of judgment.
And the third are the people of the
left. They will be to the left on the
day of judgment. They will receive their
books of deeds in their left hand.
And this is why we give precedent to our
right sides in most of our daily
activities.
Subhanahu
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.